Je regardais votre poisson.
Il est mignon.
Il a de petits yeux globuleux.
C'est le vôtre ?
J'en ai eu quand j'étais petit.
Des poissons tropicaux.
Un désastre ! Je suis parti
en laissant le chauffage allumé.
A mon retour, ils n'avaient plus
d'eau, les pauvres.
Je descends là.
Prenez soin de lui.
Allô ?
Oui, allô ?
Oui, un instant.
C'est pour vous.
Vous l'avez raté.
Ici, Donny.
Regarde.
C'est dans les tripes
que ça se passe.
Toute cette puissance,
cette chaleur, cette force.
Ouais, bien vu.
Ça donne quoi ?
Pas de téléphones
portables, compris ?
Je t'entends mal.
J'ai dit : "Plus de portables !"
J'arrive bientôt.
Yo, Slim !
- Salut.
- Ça va ?
Trois cigarettes.
Tiens.
Merci.
Ramène tes fesses.
Je te retire l'affaire.
Comme ça ?
Ne me la fais pas à moi.
Tu es déjà en mise à l'épreuve.
Tu étais sur le terrain pour
des tâches de routine. D'ailleurs...
ce gosse est hilarant.
Tu sais ce qu'il a fait hier ?
Il a pris un taxi pour le Bronx.
Au lieu de régler la course,
il sort ton badge et dit :
"Je réquisitionne le véhicule."
Il a du cran.
Tu sais qui me l'a dit ?
Le maire !
Le maire qui pensait me nommer
chef de la police de New York.
Le maire à qui je venais de te
recommander comme commissaire.
Que t'arrive-t'il, Sully ?
Trente ans !
On laisse tout s'écrouler
à cause de ce voyou ?
Je vais régler ça.
Récupère ton badge.
Peu importe ce qu'il en coûte.
Rétablis la dignité
de ce commissariat.
Lis ça et pleure.
Tu es célèbre.
Jolie photo.
Fiche le camp.
Dites à ce type que je suis prof
de Pilates, pas un pickpocket.
- Je vais...
- La ferme.
Nous y voilà.
- On va où ?
- En balade.
Il y a quoi là-bas ?
Les donuts ?
Sans rire, j'ai des droits.
- C'est pas vrai !
- Tiens ça.
- Non ! C'est vous ?
- Oui.
Je veux une dédicace.
Petit con !
Un nom !
Jax !
Ça va, Donny ?
Toujours pas de sonnette ?
Joli. C'est du vrai cuir.
Bobby...
T'es sourd ?
C'est quoi, ça ?
C'est quoi ?
- Des portables.
- Exactement.
Des portables.
- Je t'ai dit quoi ?
- J'avais compris
que tu en voulais. Désolé.
J'ai pigé, plus de portables.
Bien.
De la pacotille, pour changer.
Et le liquide ?
Tiens.
Il y a tout ?
Pour toi.
C'est tout ?
C'est tout.
- Tu veux plus ?
- Oui.
- Je me tue à la tâche.
- Vraiment ?
Oui. Il faut bien que je mange.
Ramène des objets
précieux. De l'or.
Des diamants.
Pas des babioles sans valeur.
Je ne vole pas de diamants.
Pas de diamants. J'avais oublié.
Trop personnel.
Mais pas les montres ?
Non. N'importe quel imbécile
en a une,
pas vrai ? Tu en as une ?
Très drôle.
Un vrai farceur.
Continue à voler ce que tu veux.
Tu travailleras pour moi
toute ta vie.
On doit tous rendre
des comptes à quelqu'un.
Même moi, je rends des comptes.
Je sais.
Toi aussi, tu dois
rendre des comptes.
A moi.
Excusez-moi.
Merci pour mon portefeuille.
Une chance que tu l'aies trouvé.
J'ai l'impression
que dans cette ville...
les gens n'aident pas les inconnus.
- Tu vois ?
- Oui.
C'est étrange comme la vie
crée des situations
qui rapprochent deux individus.
Quel romantisme !
C'est tout moi.
Merci.
- Je t'invite.
- Non.
Ça me gênerait. Après, tu croiras
que mon geste était intéressé.
Merci.
On vient de me signaler
une activité sur la carte bancaire
volée ce matin dans le métro.
Au Tazza.
Ni voitures de patrouille,
ni uniformes,
c'est clair ?
- Votre carte a été refusée.
- Refusée ?
C'est un signe : je dois payer.
Non ! J'ai une autre carte.
Parfois, ils y a des bugs.
La honte !
Puis-je vous parler
un instant ? En privé ?
Bien sûr.
Tu m'excuses ?
Ce n'est pas le même nom
que sur l'autre carte.
Vraiment ?
Navré. Je laisse les pourboires
de cent dollars avec celle-ci,
mais j'en ai une autre.
Non. Au temps pour moi.
- C'est réglé ?
- C'est réglé, monsieur...
- Fujimoto.
- C'est Fugimato.
Pardon.
L'autre jour, je rentrais
avec deux membres de mon groupe.
A deux rues de chez moi,
je me retourne
et je vois ce type
un peu louche...
Je t'interromps une minute.
J'ai une envie pressante.
- Ne bouge pas.
- Promis.
Excusez-moi.
Des soucis
avec une carte bancaire ?
- Il était à cette table.
- Merci.
Où est-il ?
- Il est allé aux toilettes.
- C'est là-bas,
au fond.
Je garde le pourboire ?
C'est les menottes à qui ?
- Quoi ? Qu'y a-t-il ?
- Un rat !
C'est une souris.
Vise la souris,
pas moi !
Vire-la !
Là !
Elle se sauve. Dépêche-toi !
- Où ça ? Où est-elle ?
- Sous le réfrigérateur.
Elle a filé.
Ça va ?
Tu vas bien ?
Je hais ces bêtes-là.
Bon sang, M'man !
Tu veux me tuer ?
Si j'ai une attaque, qui paiera
le loyer ?
Comme je vais
à l'église ce soir,
je me disais...
je peux te laisser
le dîner au frigo.
J'irai acheter un hamburger.
Je peux t'en préparer un.
Je le laisserai au frigo.
O.K., merci.
Tu me laisses un peu d'argent
pour le bingo ?
Je n'aime pas les paris.
Tu le sais. Tu veux finir
comme papa ?
- C'est qu'un bingo à l'église !
- O.K.
Mais je n'épongerai pas
tes dettes à ta mort.
J'ai déjà assez donné.
Ça va, le boulot ?
- La bourse monte ce mois-ci ?
- Oui.
Tu es un bon garçon.
Salut...
Lucy.
Oui, bien sûr. Je le savais.
Je t'ai aperçu de loin.
Je ne savais pas si c'était toi,
mais c'est toi.
Ça faisait un bail.
- Trois mois.
- C'est ça.
Ça va ?
- Je vais bien.
- Bien.
- C'est bien.
- Rien de neuf.
C'est ma pause déjeuner.
J'ai essayé de t'appeler,
mais ton téléphone
devait être coupé.
Non, j'en ai changé.
On devrait manger ensemble
un midi pour bavarder.
- Là, je ne peux pas...
- Je suis enceinte.
Tu es quoi ?
Enceinte.
Félicitations. C'est formidable.
De combien ?
Trois mois.
Tu as bien dit trois ?
Il est de toi.
Attends... On ne l'a fait
que cette nuit-là.
En réalité,
on l'a fait plusieurs fois.
Oui, mais seulement
cette nuit-là.
Il suffit d'une fois.
Tu es sûre qu'il est de moi ?
C'est une question légitime !
- Tu me prends pour une pute ?
- C'était un coup d'un soir !
Parle pour toi !
J'ai essayé de t'appeler.
Écoute...
- Ne me touche pas !
- Excusez-moi !
Tout va bien ?
Très bien. C'est ma petite amie.
La bonne blague.
Tout va bien.
Tu veux me faire arrêter ?
Écoute-moi !
Tu es venue me chercher. N'espère
pas que je te coure après.
Si tu ne veux pas
me parler, ça me va.
Je ne te cherchais pas. Ça fait
trois mois que renoncé à toi.
Je t'ai aperçu donc j'ai voulu
te prévenir que tu aurais
un enfant, au cas où tu le
croiserais. Voilà, tu sais.
Connard.
Attends, s'il te plaît.
Vous désirez ?
- Une cigarette.
- Quoi ?
Une cigarette.
Comment vous le savez ?
- Quoi ?
- Mon nom. Lucy.
Je dois être médium.
NE M'ATTENDS PAS. MAMAN
Assez ! Ça suffit.
Les dettes de ton père
te reviennent.
Désormais, tu bosses pour moi.
Qui je suis ?
Inspecteur Bobby Correlli.
Voilà qui je suis.
Juste là.
Tu es un écureuil ?
Stop ! Au nom de la loi !
Ta gueule !
Si je t'embarque,
ça ne va pas rigoler !
Joli, le coup
de la porte vitrée.
Ça fait très inspecteur Harry.
C'est de ta faute.
Tu m'as dit quoi qu'il en coûte.
Merci, Pete.
C'est ce que j'aime chez toi.
Tu fais les choses à ta façon,
sans craindre
le qu'en-dira-t-on.
Pourquoi changer maintenant ?
J'ai fonctionné comme ça
toute ma vie.
Je ne suis bon à rien d'autre.
- Et ensuite ?
- Ensuite ?
Je vais récupérer mon badge,
même si je dois tuer ce petit con.
Bonjour.
Tu es qui ?
Carl.
Je pensais que
tu serais au bureau.
C'est qui ?
- Carl.
- Ça, je sais.
Qu'est-ce qu'il fiche ici,
dans mon peignoir ?
- Tu ne lui as rien dit ?
- Je n'en ai pas eu l'occasion.
Voilà, Bob. Je suis...
un ami de ta mère.
Un ami du bingo.
- Est-ce que tous les deux... ?
- Non !
Ce n'est pas ce que tu crois.
On est amis de longue date.
Je ne voulais pas t'en parler,
mais je pense qu'il est temps.
On va emménager ensemble.
Ce n'est pas ce que tu crois.
- Je vais le tuer !
- S'il te plaît, non !
C'est un ancien Marine.
Que s'est-il passé ?
Tu as une tête de mort-vivant.
La mort serait un soulagement
à côté du merdier qu'est ma vie.
Parle. Je suis derrière toi.
Raconte-moi.
J'ai mis une fille enceinte.
C'est très drôle. Marre-toi.
Oui, je suis derrière toi.
Très loin derrière toi.
D'ailleurs, tu ne me vois plus.
Merci.
Je suis foutu.
- C'est elle qui t'a cogné ?
- Je suis tombé dans l'escalier.
D'accord.
Elle va garder le gamin ?
Je n'en sais rien.
On n'en a pas parlé.
Pourquoi voudrait-elle garder
un bébé sans père ?
Surtout le tien.
Donne-lui du fric
pour qu'elle s'en débarrasse.
Tu seras dans les couches sales
jusqu'au cou.
Comme pour une mission sur la lune,
avorte.
Vous savez
où je peux trouver Lucy ?
- Qui la demande ?
- Euh... moi.
Qui es-tu ?
Un ami à elle. Un ami d'enfance.
- Tu es aussi de l'Ohio ?
- Oui.
Elle a grandi au Texas,
connard. Va-t'en.
Elle bosse encore ici ?
Je veux juste lui parler.
Comme la moitié des types ici.
Dégage ou je te dégage.
Tu as trouvé ça tout seul ?
Tu le connais ?
C'est moi !
Ne l'approche plus !
Dégage !
Quoi ? Non, attends !
Pas toi.
Que fais-tu ici ?
Je suis désolé pour le...
En fait...
J'étais sous le choc quand tu...
Quand on annonce ça
à un garçon...
Est-ce que tu veux le garder ?
Si je veux le garder ?
On ne parle pas
d'un chien errant.
Je le sais. Je dis juste que...
Que quoi ? Que dis-tu ?
Parce que j'écoute,
mais je n'entends rien.
Si tu ne veux pas le garder,
je t'aiderai pour l'argent.
Waouh ! On peut compter sur toi.
Qu'attends-tu de moi ?
Je n'attends rien de toi.
C'est toi qui es venu me trouver.
Je ne vois pas pourquoi
tu voudrais le garder.
Pourquoi avoir un enfant avec
un père minable qui n'en veut pas
et une mère qui n'a pas
les moyens de l'élever ?
J'essaie de t'aider, là.
Tu en as fait assez, merci.
On ne peut pas te parler. Tu fais
la maligne et tu te sauves.
Si j'étais si maligne,
j'aurais passé mon chemin.
Là ! Tu vois ?
J'essaie de faire ce qu'il faut.
Je vais trouver un bon médecin
et c'est moi qui paie.
Qu'en dis-tu ?
Que tu es un connard.
Mais j'y penserai.
Attends !
Comment je peux te joindre ?
Appelle ici.
Je crèche
dans la réserve de Gomer.
Combien ?
Non. Je n'ai pas
d'assurance santé.
Pas de consultation gratuite,
je tiens à payer.
J'en ai conscience, mais...
Si je paie cash, on ne peut pas
trouver un arrangement ?
Allô ? Allô ?
Je passais chercher
le reste de mes affaires.
Dis quelque chose.
Sinon quoi ?
Ton copain va me frapper ?
C'est un homme bien.
Il a besoin de moi.
Et moi ? Moi aussi,
j'ai besoin de toi.
Bien sûr que non.
Tu t'occupes de moi.
Je ne veux pas être
un fardeau pour toi.
Avec Carl,
on prend soin de l'autre.
Ça fait partie de l'arrangement
avec ton pote de bingo ?
Je l'aime.
Pas comme j'aimais ton père,
ni comme je t'aime, toi.
C'est différent.
Qui sait ? Un jour, avec la bonne
personne, tu comprendras.
Ce sera évident.
Je dois y aller.
Il veut t'inviter
à dîner demain soir.
Repartir de zéro.
Voilà son numéro.
Je suis heureuse.
Tu ne peux pas l'être pour moi ?
Règle ton fer à repasser. Évite
de brûler ses chemises aussi.
Salut, Jax.
Non, aujourd'hui, j'ai des trucs
à régler. Je ne peux pas.
Bobby ? Bobby Correlli ?
- C'est bien toi ?
- Quoi ?
C'est ton nom ?
- Tu vis ici ?
- Qui ?
- Toi. Bobby.
- Moi, c'est Tommy.
- Tommy ?
- Je rendais visite à ma tante.
- Tu ne vis pas là ?
- Non.
Bonjour, Bobby. Félicitations
pour les fiançailles de ta mère.
Ils m'ont trouvé !
J'ignore comment,
mais ils m'ont trouvé.
- Qui ça ?
- Les flics !
Mon appart grouillait de flics.
- Qui m'a vendu ?
- Aucune idée.
C'est peut-être ta copine
qui leur a balancé ton nom.
Elle ne sait rien.
- Ils t'ont suivi ?
- Non.
- Qu'en sais-tu ?
- Tu ne risques rien.
Tu as un plan ?
Pas vraiment. Je crois
que je vais faire profil bas.
Tu sais où faire le truc ?
L'hôpital Elmsview. J'y suis né,
ça doit être un bon hôpital.
Il n'y a qu'à voir
ce que tu es devenu.
Il me faudrait 100 dollars
pour payer un motel.
- Je dors où sans fric ?
- Pars.
Je n'ai pas d'argent.
Pas pour toi.
Je n'ai nulle part où aller.
Je ne te donnerai rien.
Tu déconnes ?
Je n'ai pas besoin de toi.
Je peux voler des portefeuilles.
Tu aurais vingt dollars ? Non ?
Qu'est-ce qui cloche chez lui ?
- Quoi ?
- Moi, j'éviterais le métro.
- Prends un taxi.
- Oui. Merci.
Allô, Carl ? C'est Bobby.
Le type à qui
tu as collé un poing.
Oui... Ma mère est là ?
Elle dort ?
Non, je ne me suis pas rendu
compte de l'heure.
Dis-lui que je vous verrai
demain, d'accord ?
Non, tout va bien.
Merci. A plus.
Pourquoi tu chuchotes ?
Si c'est pour tambouriner
à la porte, autant crier.
Je suis passé te dire qu'on avait
rendez-vous demain à 14h.
J'espère que ça te convient.
Il est 3h du matin donc...
je te vois dans onze heures.
La prochaine fois, appelle.
Ah non, c'est vrai !
Tu n'appelles pas.
Attends.
J'ai eu une dure soirée. Je peux
entrer pour prendre un verre ?
Au cas où tu n'aurais pas vu,
on est fermé.
Je peux entrer une minute ?
Rien qu'une minute ?
Je n'ai nulle part où aller.
S'il te plaît.
Une minute.
Tu aurais une cigarette ?
Une femme enceinte ne fume pas.
- Tu le veux toujours, ce verre ?
- Oui. Un scotch, merci.
Tu veux en parler ?
De quoi ?
De la misère
dans laquelle tu croupis.
Dans laquelle je croupis ? Vous
parlez tous comme ça au Texas ?
- Comment sais-tu d'où je viens ?
- Je sais quelques trucs.
Alors monsieur
je-sais-quelques-trucs,
pourquoi venir frapper
à ma porte en pleine nuit ?
J'ai été expulsé.
J'ai une question.
Le Pierrafeu au bar,
c'est ton mec ?
- Pourquoi ? Tu es jaloux ?
- Curieux.
Non.
Enfin... Plus maintenant.
Il veille sur moi, c'est tout.
En grand frère protecteur.
D'ailleurs, il te tuerait
sûrement s'il te savait ici.
Surtout s'il savait
que c'est toi le père.
- Il est au courant pour... ?
- Oui.
Pourquoi ces questions ?
Je n'en sais rien.
Comme on est très différents,
lui et moi, je me demandais...
pourquoi ce soir-là...
Si c'est ça, ton genre
d'hommes, pourquoi...
Oublie.
Tu veux savoir pourquoi
j'ai passé la nuit avec toi ?
Ça fait trois mois
que je me le demande.
- C'est à cause de tes yeux.
- De mes yeux ?
Oui. Ils me plaisaient beaucoup.
Tu as de très gentils yeux.
Ils me rappellent
ceux de mon père.
Tu as couché avec moi
pour mes beaux yeux.
Tes gentils yeux.
Et aussi, j'aimais
discuter avec toi.
Je te trouvais drôle,
sympathique et...
tu avais un joli cul.
Je t'ai laissé me raccompagner.
Une fois chez moi,
tu n'as rien tenté.
Tu as souri et tu m'as remerciée
pour cette excellente soirée.
- Puis tu as dit...
- Bonne nuit.
Je ne devais pas vouloir
que la soirée s'arrête là.
Avec le recul, j'aurais dû
y mettre un terme plus tôt.
Trois minutes plus tôt,
si je me souviens bien.
En parlant de minutes...
la tienne est écoulée.
Une grosse journée
m'attend demain.
Écoute... Tu n'es pas obligé
de m'accompagner.
Laisse-moi l'argent
et l'adresse demain matin.
J'ai promis de t'emmener chez
un bon médecin, je t'y emmène.
En personne.
- Tu n'es pas obligé.
- Je le ferai quand même.
Rendez-vous à 13h45,
à l'angle de la 39ème rue
et de la 5ème avenue,
à l'hôpital Elmsview.
Très bien.
A demain. Merci pour le verre.
Vous auriez une clope ?
Lucy ? C'est Bobby.
J'ai un problème.
Je récapitule.
L'argent est chez toi, mais
tu veux que j'aille le chercher.
C'est ça.
Parce que si ton propriétaire
te voit, il appellera les flics
car tu as des loyers de retard.
Exact.
Donc tu veux que j'entre
chez toi discrètement
pour récupérer l'argent et
si on me voit, je prétends être
- la femme de ménage.
- Oui.
C'est louche, non ?
Tu as raison.
C'est nul. Dis que tu viens voir
ta tante. Non, j'ai déjà dit ça.
Tiens-t'en à l'histoire
de la femme de ménage.
Ça va marcher.
D'accord ?
Surtout, tu ne me connais pas
et tu ignores où je suis.
Si je ne te connais pas,
j'ignore où tu es.
Exactement.
Dis-moi la vérité.
Je te l'ai dit : c'est
mon appart, mes clés, mon fric.
Si je pouvais y aller
moi-même, j'irais.
Si tu ne le sens pas,
tant pis, mais...
je n'ai pas l'argent.
Cet endroit aurait effectivement
besoin d'une femme de ménage.
Tu l'as ?
Bon boulot.
Les femmes, c'est le Mal.
Tu tombes mal.
Je pars faire le truc.
Tu me raconteras la fin.
Très drôle.
Tu l'as dit à tout le monde ?
- Combien ?
- 18 dollars.
Fais gaffe, connard.
Bonjour. Lucy Atwood.
J'ai un rendez-vous.
- A quelle heure ?
- Maintenant.
- Merci.
- Remplissez ça.
- Mes permis et numéro de sécu ?
- Oui, s'il vous plaît.
- Qu'y a-t-il ?
- Je ne peux pas faire ça.
Toi, tu n'auras rien à faire.
Moi si. Tu as déjà fait ta part.
- On devrait peut-être attendre.
- Attendre ?
Tu crois que si je prends
deux aspirines, ça passera ?
- Je dis juste que peut-être...
- Non. Ne commence pas.
J'ai déjà pesé
le pour et le contre.
Tu m'as bien fait comprendre ce
que tu en pensais. Finissons-en.
On devrait attendre.
- Tu veux attendre ?
- Oui.
Tu veux attendre ?
Connard !
Pourquoi tu me frappes ?
Je te déteste.
- Je te déteste !
- Calme-toi.
Donne-moi l'argent.
Je le ferai sans toi.
- Où tu l'as mis ?
- On trouvera une solution.
- Calme-toi. On va s'arranger.
- Je te déteste !
- Arrête !
- Donne-moi le fric.
Tu peux me faire confiance ?
- Cours.
- Quoi ?
Cours !
Viens.
Tu plaisantes ?
- Allez ! Grimpe.
- Non.
Taxi !
Démarrez !
Merci.
Bob ! Tu es en avance.
J'avais bien précisé
le dîner à ta mère ?
Oui, mais on était
dans le quartier.
Je vois. Entrez donc ! Bonjour.
J'allais descendre à l'épicerie
pour ta mère.
Elle m'a tout noté
- sur une liste.
- Elle n'est pas là ?
Elle a emmené
mes petits-fils au parc.
Ma fille me les confie
une fois par semaine.
Mignons, mais filous !
Des jumeaux.
- Tu dois être sa copine ?
- Non.
Très bien, je...
Il faut que j'y aille.
- Vous m'accompagnez ?
- Non.
Vous voulez rester là ?
- Oui. On va attendre ma mère.
- Entendu.
Mince ! Je suis vraiment désolé,
Bob. Tu sais...
J'aime ta mère. Je suis
très protecteur avec elle.
Moi aussi.
C'est Bobby, connard.
- Tu m'expliques ?
- Quoi ? Que veux-tu savoir ?
A ton avis ?
Pourquoi les flics
nous ont-ils poursuivis ?
Dans quelle galère
m'as-tu embarquée ?
Qui est Carl ? Et surtout,
qui es-tu, toi ?
Carl est le copain de ma mère.
Elle vient d'emménager chez lui.
Je vois. Et les flics ?
Je ne travaille pas
vraiment à Wall Street.
Ça exclut le délit d'initié.
Je suis un pickpocket.
Ça te fait rire ?
Un pickpocket ?
Et la moitié de la police
de New York serait après toi ?
Tu sais qu'on a volé
le badge d'un flic ?
Ce n'est pas vrai.
C'est génial.
Vraiment.
Le père de mon enfant
dévalise les vieilles dames.
Je ne vole pas ceux qui ont
l'air plus fauchés que moi.
Tu es un Robin des Bois.
- Tu ne sais rien de ma vie.
- Tu as raison.
- Je ne te connais pas.
- Qu'est-ce que tu racontes ?
Je suis toujours l'homme
que tu as rencontré au bar,
- sauf que j'ai un autre métier.
- Tu es dingue ?
Ce n'est pas un métier.
Tu voles.
Je t'interdis de me juger.
Mon père m'a laissé 500.000
dollars de dettes de jeu
et une mère sans emploi.
Je n'avais pas le choix.
Tu pouvais prévenir les flics.
Il menaçait de tuer ma mère.
Tu pourrais arrêter.
Je lui dois encore
100.000 dollars.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Je prends l'argent.
Je refuse d'avoir un enfant
qui devra rendre visite
à son père en prison à Noël.
Où l'as-tu mis ?
- Il est dans ma veste.
- Non. Il n'y a rien.
Qu'est-ce que tu me chantes ?
Il n'y est pas.
Qu'en as-tu fait ?
- Tu l'as perdu ?
- Pourquoi moi ?
- Il était dans ta veste.
- Tu l'as récupéré à l'hôpital.
Je n'ai pas pu. Tu m'as bloqué
les bras et embrassée,
rappelle-toi.
Il est peut-être tombé
dans le taxi ou...
quand ce type t'a bousculé.
Le coup classique.
Le pickpocket
s'est fait détrousser.
Je rêve !
Haut les mains !
Videz vos poches, monsieur.
Trop tard.
Tu es en avance. Où est Carl ?
- A l'épicerie.
- Allez jouer
avec vos hamsters.
Bonjour.
Je suis sa mère, Rita.
Lucy.
Bobby ne m'avait pas présenté
de fille depuis une éternité.
- Vous devez...
- Partir. Elle partait.
Et ce n'est qu'une amie.
Je passerai
- te voir pour parler du truc.
- Attends !
Ne sois pas grossier.
Invite-la à dîner ici.
Ce soir, c'est lasagnes,
son plat préféré.
Miam !
Avec plaisir.
- Je vais commencer à cuisiner.
- Je viens vous aider.
- Tu as si faim que ça ?
- Je mange pour deux.
Ne dis rien à ma mère.
Je ne voudrais pas
contrarier mamie.
Monsieur,
- on joue à un jeu de société ?
- Non.
- A un jeu vidéo ?
Aux gendarmes
et au voleur ?
Certainement pas.
D'où le connais-tu ?
On a un ami commun.
Je crois
que tu lui plais beaucoup.
A quoi le voyez-vous ?
Il est nerveux quand une fille
lui plaît. A croire qu'il refuse
de le lui montrer. Tu sais
comment sont les garçons.
Toujours à tirer les nattes
des filles qu'ils apprécient.
Crap ?
Craps. C'est le nom du jeu.
Un jeu très sérieux.
7 ou 11 au premier jet,
c'est gagné.
2, 3, 12 au premier jet,
c'est perdu. Ensuite, 4...
5, 6, 8, 9, 10, c'est vos points,
le nombre à obtenir pour gagner.
Si vous refaites un 7,
vous perdez votre tour.
Compris ? Nicky, commence.
Non, il faut d'abord miser. Placez
vos mises, les garçons ! Voilà.
Lance les dés.
4. C'est ce qu'on appelle
un "Little Joe". Tu dois
en refaire un pour gagner.
Amuse-toi ! Souffle sur les dés.
Allez ! Un Little Joe !
- J'ai gagné.
- Non, tu perds ton tour.
On gagne tes bonbons.
Tu vois ce que c'est de parier ?
- A ton tour.
- Madame,
ça vous tente un peu d'action ?
J'ai eu ma dose d'action
pour aujourd'hui. Merci.
J'apporte les tomates fraîches.
C'est là-bas que ça se passe.
Laissez-moi vous aider.
Non, merci. Ça ira.
Et puis...
mi casa su casa.
Et j'ai une excuse pour rejoindre
la plus belle femme du monde.
Bonjour, chérie.
Au nom de Jésus,
nous te prions. Amen.
Alors, Bob, Rita m'a dit que
- tu travaillais à la Bourse ?
- Oui.
- Ça se passe comment pour toi ?
- Il y a des hauts et des bas.
Je croyais que tu avais
du mal à payer ton loyer.
Si tu cherches un boulot
stable, viens me voir.
Appelle-moi.
Il tient une bijouterie
en ville.
Les diamants sont
les meilleurs amis d'une femme.
- Exact. Et ?
- Ne pas acheter au détail.
Je tâcherai de m'en souvenir.
Si tu connais quelqu'un qui
cherche une bague de fiançailles,
appelle Carl.
Il lui fera un prix.
Merci, M'man.
Lucy est photographe
professionnelle.
Vraiment ?
En freelance, surtout.
Mais en ce moment, je travaille
à mi-temps dans un bar.
Ça paie mal, mais je gagne
ma vie honnêtement.
Tu as bien raison.
Comme ça, tu es du Texas ?
D'ailleurs, j'y retourne
- samedi.
- Tu repars ?
Je crois que je vais
réemménager avec ma sœur,
faire des portraits pour un
studio photo, ce genre de choses.
Tu avais prévu
de m'en parler quand ?
En réalité,
je n'ai rien prévu avec toi.
- Comment sont les lasagnes ?
- Délicieuses.
Excellentes.
Excusez-moi.
Tu veux aller te rafraîchir ?
Je peux te montrer les toilettes.
C'est dans la salle de bain.
Lucy, ça va ?
- Qu'y a-t-il ?
- Appelle une ambulance !
Respire.
Je n'accouche pas, abruti. Je ne
suis enceinte que de trois mois.
Et merde !
Pourquoi tu ne m'as rien dit ?
Pour ne pas t'inquiéter.
M'inquiéter ? En quoi devenir
grand-mère devrait m'inquiéter ?
Elle veut le garder ?
Je ne sais pas.
Tu l'aimes ?
Je n'en sais rien.
Je veux dire...
Je n'y connais rien.
Comment on le sait ?
Comment t'es-tu senti quand
elle a dit qu'elle partait ?
Écœuré.
Et sur le chemin de l'hôpital,
comment te sentais-tu ?
Il faut parfois manquer de tout
perdre pour mesurer sa chance.
Docteur Phil.
Bon. Je vais y aller
et vous laisser seuls.
Salut.
Le médecin a dit
que tu t'en remettrais.
Tu as seulement besoin de repos.
Et le bébé ?
Il va bien.
Quoi ?
Ne t'inquiète pas.
Il va bien, toi aussi.
J'espérais qu'il règle
son sort tout seul.
Je ne sais pas
ce que je vais faire.
Non. Ce qu'on va faire.
Tu n'es plus seule. On est deux.
D'accord ?
Sois sérieux.
Tu ne veux pas d'enfant.
On se connaît à peine.
Tu ne te rappelais même pas
mon nom il y a quelques jours.
C'est ce que tu crois ?
Que j'avais oublié ton nom ?
Tu veux la vérité ?
Oui. Ce serait bien,
pour une fois.
Je n'arrêtais pas de penser
à toi après cette nuit-là.
Je devenais dingue
tellement je pensais à toi.
Et quand je t'ai enfin sortie
de ma tête, paf ! Tu étais là,
juste devant moi.
J'étais si nerveux
que je bafouillais.
Pourquoi tu ne m'as pas appelée ?
J'avais peur.
En me réveillant ce matin-là,
je t'ai regardée.
Tu étais si belle.
Tu es magnifique.
Je ne voulais pas partir.
Ça ne m'était jamais arrivé.
J'ai voulu te laisser
mon numéro, mais je n'ai pas pu.
J'ai déchiré le papier et noté
un faux numéro à la place.
Puis j'ai réécrit mon numéro,
déchiré, et ainsi de suite.
A la fin, j'ai mis
tous les papiers dans ma poche.
En partant, j'en ai pioché un
en me disant :
"Si c'est le bon numéro,
c'est que c'est écrit.
Laissons le destin en décider."
Je sais.
Je suis un connard. J'ai été
bête. Je l'ai regretté, mais...
Je n'ai pas oublié
ton nom, Lucy.
Je n'ai pas réussi.
J'ai essayé, crois-moi.
Pourquoi je te croirais ?
Je la trimballe
depuis trois mois.
J'ai des problèmes d'engagement.
J'ai vu.
Tu ne restes même pas fidèle
à une marque de cigarettes.
Cette fois, je ne me sauverai pas.
J'en prends l'engagement.
Je ne peux pas être
avec quelqu'un qui vole.
Alors c'est fini.
J'arrête.
Donne-moi une chance.
Je te le prouverai
si tu m'en donnes la chance.
Et tu arrêteras ?
Tu peux arrêter ? Comme ça ?
Pour moi ?
Prenez une chambre, vous deux !
Les visites sont terminées
et vous devez vous reposer.
Tu es de mèche avec les flics ?
Tu es de mèche
avec les flics ? Toi ?
La ferme !
Je devrais te tuer.
Pourquoi m'as-tu balancé ?
T'es pas mon pote.
J'ai sacrifié ma vie, Jax.
J'ai sacrifié ma vie !
Tu n'es pas mon ami.
Il ne fallait pas foutre le bordel
dans mes affaires.
Voler le badge d'un flic ?
Tu m'en as tiré de l'argent ?
Les flics ont débarqué chez moi.
Ici même !
Tu vas bosser pour moi.
Ça t'amuse ?
Tu trouves ça drôle ?
Je leur ai dit où tu habitais.
Je leur ai dit
où et quand te trouver.
- Tu m'as fait dévaliser ?
- En effet.
Je savais
que tu en aurais sur toi,
monsieur Moralité.
Tu allais assumer ce merdier
avec ta copine.
Elle n'a pas un rond.
Cet ami t'a rendu service.
Cet ami m'a balancé.
Un nom !
Lui ai-je reproché ?
Tu sais pourquoi ?
Parce que ça marche comme ça.
C'est le business.
Ça n'a rien de personnel.
C'est fini.
Minute !
- Attends, écoute.
- Le lieutenant Sullivan.
Tu veux récupérer tes 50.000 $
plus ce que je te dois ?
C'est trop tard.
Vas-y, appelle les flics.
Ils n'ont rien contre moi.
Je n'ai pas le badge.
- Sans le badge, ils n'ont rien.
- Donny, verrouille la porte !
- Rien !
- La partie est finie.
J'ai un plan qui va rapporter
gros. Finies les combines.
Tu aimes les diamants ?
Parle.
Ça a intérêt à être du lourd.
Je vais te fournir des diamants.
Salut.
- Comment te sens-tu ?
- Beaucoup mieux.
Je devrais sortir
cet après-midi.
Ils attendent
mes résultats d'analyse
par précaution.
Ça va ?
Oui. Ça va.
C'est pour moi ?
Oui, désolé.
Merci.
Écoute, Lucy...
Je sais que je t'ai dit
que j'allais arrêter,
mais...
il s'est passé un truc. Du coup,
j'ai une dernière chose à régler.
De quoi tu parles ?
Disons que c'est un peu
compliqué.
Tu dois me faire confiance.
Je t'en parle uniquement
car je veux être honnête
- avec toi.
- Honnête avec moi ?
Tu ne m'as rien dit.
Je sais. Je n'ai pas
le droit d'en parler.
J'aimerais, pourtant.
N'essaie pas de t'enfuir.
N'en parle à personne.
Sinon je jure devant Dieu
que je te tue, et elle aussi.
Je te promets qu'après-demain,
tout sera fini. J'arrêterai.
Demain, je serai partie.
J'ai un avion à prendre.
Donne-moi 24h.
Je t'expliquerai.
Je t'aime.
Allô, Carl ? C'est Bobby.
J'aurais besoin d'un service.
C'est fermé.
Je suis l'ami de Bobby.
Bien sûr.
Il m'a prévenu de votre venue.
Entrez. Moi, c'est Carl.
- Dennis.
- Enchanté.
Navré pour le retard.
Je sors du boulot.
Ça ne fait rien. Si j'ai bien
compris, vous et Bobby travaillez
ensemble à Wall Street ?
Non, je suis son patron.
Vous cherchez bien
une bague de fiançailles ?
Je vais être franc :
je n'y connais strictement rien
en bijoux. Je n'en porte pas.
- Je vous pardonne.
- Mais...
ma fiancée a des goûts de luxe
et je veux lui faire plaisir.
Votre budget ?
J'ai un budget d'environ...
30.000 dollars.
J'espère que ça suffira.
30.000 dollars ? Vous devez
vraiment bien gagner votre vie.
Je me débrouille.
Très bien. Je vais vous
montrer quelque chose.
J'ai ici des diamants
2,5 à 3 carats,
de pureté VVS 1 ou 2, et...
de couleur J dans l'ensemble.
- C'est une bague de fiançailles ?
- Oui.
Si un des diamants vous plaît,
mais pas la monture,
on peut le sertir sur une bague
à sa grand-mère, par exemple.
Quel style préfère-t-elle ?
Le mariage... quel stress !
Je croyais qu'il n'y avait
qu'un style de bague.
Si j'avais su
qu'il y en avait tant !
Vous devriez faire du repérage.
Faites le tour des bijouteries
avec elle
ce week-end et quand vous êtes
fixé, revenez me voir.
Je reçois du monde ce soir
et j'espérais vraiment...
avoir une bague à lui offrir.
Ce sera une grosse soirée.
Je ne peux pas les amener.
J'ai une idée.
- J'ai 15.000 dollars.
- Ce n'est pas la question.
Écoutez au moins
ce que je propose.
Je vous verse un acompte.
Vous choisissez quelques bagues
qui, selon vous, lui plairaient.
On va chez moi, c'est à côté.
Je sais bien que vous êtes
un ami de Bobby, mais...
N'importe lesquelles, tant qu'on
reste dans cette gamme de prix.
Je paierai le reste sur place.
Il y a là plus d'un demi million
de dollars en diamants.
Je peux vous faire un chèque
pour la totalité.
Je n'aime pas
les sortir d'ici.
J'ai assez de liquide chez moi
pour régler le reste.
C'est une vente assurée. Elle
choisira en moins d'une seconde,
- la plus chère, sans doute.
- Comme Bobby vous connait,
je prends l'argent.
Je le mets dans le coffre et
on pourra aller la surprendre.
Je peux aussi payer en une fois.
Non, ça ira.
Votre idée me plaît.
Et si je gardais le liquide
pour vous payer comptant ?
Je fais déjà un effort
en sortant les diamants.
Je préfère laisser l'argent ici.
Sûr ? Ça ne me gêne
pas de payer en une fois.
Certain !
Et d'ailleurs, permettez-moi...
de vous faire cadeau
de cette paire
de magnifiques boucles d'oreilles.
- Prêt ?
- Oui.
- J'ai des souvenirs ici.
- Oui ?
J'aurais besoin d'un service.
Je peux emprunter
votre téléphone ?
Je veux m'assurer
qu'elle est rentrée.
Hier, j'ai fait tomber le mien
dans les toilettes.
Vraiment ?
Mon père y a fait
tomber ses clés.
Appelez les secours !
Donnez-moi ça.
Bon sang !
Vous avez vu d'où il venait ?
La police.
Oui, j'ai besoin d'assistance.
On vient de me dévaliser,
dans West Broadway.
Dites-leur qu'il porte
une veste verte.
Il a une veste militaire
et des cheveux blonds-roux.
Il y a toute ma vie
dans cette valise.
Mon Dieu !
Je m'en veux.
Il y avait plus
de 500.000 dollars en diamants
- et en liquide.
- Je suis désolé. Il est arrivé
comme un éclair.
Vous allez bien, au moins ?
Vous n'y êtes pour rien.
Je suis désolé.
Je me sens responsable.
Je m'en veux terriblement.
Mais ne vous en faites pas.
Les flics vont le retrouver.
Ils le coinceront, c'est sûr.
Tu en as mis du temps, bordel !
Il a eu le cran de me demander
de l'accompagner chez les flics
pour témoigner.
Moi, j'étais là : "En fait...
Ma fiancée m'attend.
Je dois y aller."
Ta fiancée ?
Sa fiancée !
Parce qu'on est ensemble ?
- Très drôle. Où est Bobby ?
- Il n'est pas là.
Tu fais quoi ?
On devait attendre
d'être tous là pour...
Écoute-moi bien.
Bobby aura que dalle.
Toi, je te filerai une bague
et ensuite,
je ferme boutique. Donny !
- Fermer boutique ?
- La porte !
Tu vas où ?
Comme si j'allais te le dire !
A terre !
Les mains sur la tête !
Ça va ?
Tant mieux.
Quelle marque ?
Je n'en sais rien.
C'est une cigarette.
J'ai arrêté.
De fumer ou de voler ?
Les deux.
C'est quoi ?
Je me mettrais bien à genoux,
mais dans le caniveau,
ce ne serait pas très romantique.
Tu ne l'as pas volée
lors de ton dernier casse ?
Carl m'a proposé une affaire
en or. Et même une remise.
Je sais.
Carl est venu à l'hôpital. Il m'a
dit ce que vous maniganciez.
Et tu as laissé Gomer
me flanquer une raclée ?
J'étais énervée que
tu ne me le dises pas toi-même.
Il a fait du bon boulot, non ?
Tu es sûre ?
Alors...
C'est quoi la suite ?
Je peux te poser une question ?
Bien sûr.
- Il y a des métros au Texas ?
- Ne commence pas !